bonjour tout le monde, désolé pour le masque
mais malheureusement je ne peux pas encore parler
sans l'aide je veux faire ça
cette vidéo parce que trop
les gens et fendi undergamba ceci
[ __ ] il a même vu ça
personnellement ça a bouleversé ma vie depuis
environ 10 jours
c'était mon père en fait
ce qui surtout vu que j'ai pensé pendant des années
cours critique avec vol de coffre-fort a
un canular beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
prêt déjà alors que je sais beaucoup
répondre à nos questions ci-dessus peut
instigate envoyé pour vous dès le début
je cisco il y a un mois j'étais mauvais avec
fièvre et toux sèche
J'ai été à la maison des Français tu vises quoi
une entreprise de scooters électriques e
Je suis rentré un peu à la maison parce que
Je ne voulais pas quitter mes garçons
donc j'ai peut-être un peu oublié
[Musique]
J'ai vécu tranquillement pendant un mois
bonjour de carlo où la société qui
ils m'ont appelé pour aller en prendre un
jour où j'ai tout commencé normalement
Je ne me suis pas arrêté au turin registre
milan et environ une heure j'ai fait le mien
journée avec des collègues arrivent quand
je suis rentré vers 20h alors
le cadastre recense des dizaines de DVD mais peut-être savez-vous
qu'est-ce que j'avais mangé
alors le pauvre vendredi soir je vais à
dormir
à ce point le samedi matin suivant
en plus mardi j'étais malade je me suis réveillé là
le matin où je suis venu je n'avais pas envie
manger et puis à partir de mardi ce sera ça
détresse respiratoire
cette forte fièvre 38 j'ai oublié
tant est dur et sérieux que non
ça m'a fait dormir
mon frère est venu chez moi missive
dans l'état de son mari
appelons l'ambulance ça fait dix jours
que je me tiens ici et que j'ai vécu au-delà de ça
pas la mort de mon père malheureusement
vécu un vrai esprit
saviez-vous que papa I à propos de mon père
alors avouons les frères
qu'est-ce que tu me fais non ne me dis rien pourquoi
J'ai en moi je savais si c'était
statut positif vu venir à la dialyse
ça ne se ferait pas mais je me suis forcé
ne rien savoir
Bonjour, j'ai reçu un message de
mes condoléances j'ai pas tout compris
crois que mon père a une relation
beau fortissimo mais j'y suis allé
réservations je l'ai vécu un an et demi depuis
quand ma mère est morte je me suis pris
prendre soin de lui lui apporte plus que pas
Je peux l'aider jusqu'au dernier pas
pouvoir assister à ses dernières funérailles
câlin très fort
[Musique]
tu sais avant j'aimais vraiment m'amuser
que j'aimais qu'elle soit insouciante et
maintenant je me rends compte qu'ils ont créé
rien et il n'y a pas pareil quand
ces choses arrivent tu réalises que c'en est une
belle voiture ou beau boulot
une montre de vêtements mais quand êtes-vous
voilà vous comprenez que ce sera la santé donc rien
mais pour dîner une promenade
bonne journée à la plage parce que quand on
nous vivons la normalité
nous tenons tout pour acquis et quand nous
sont-ils positifs du coup que le
la famille amoureuse est la plus belle des choses
tu sais maintenant ce que ce sera pour toi plus tard
tu sais quand tu sortiras ce que ce sera
arrangé parfait alors je ne me
Je comprends parfaitement ce qui va se passer
sûrement le pire moment sera
quand l'inter à la maison et que je suis parti
mon père aimerait vraiment ça
qu'est-ce qu'ici pour combien c'était mauvais là-bas
conduire à trouver qui l'a aidé oui là
nous sommes tous en difficulté